fast api makes it quicker and easier to
develop apis with python
tommy will show you how it works in this
course hey guys
welcome to this fast api crash course
fast api is a modern
fast and high performance web framework
for building apis with python
in this video i will show you what you
need to get started working with fast
api
fast api also has a very good and easy
to follow documentation
which i can also recommend and it is
also a great framework for building web
applications with python
during this tutorial there are some tips
and keynotes that you might want to take
down
but i already did this for you so i made
a fast api cheat sheet
in which you can download for free using
the link in the description below
and if you like more tutorials like this
don't forget to check out my channel at
codytomi
where i teach more on python and web
development in general
the only requirement for this tutorial
is that you have the basic knowledge of
python and you have python
installed on your computer with a
minimum version of 3.6 or io
having all this said let's dive straight
into this video
so the first thing we're going to be
talking about is how we are going to
install fast api now to install fast api
on your computer on your laptop
is very easy because fast api is a
python
framework so we're going to use the
python package manager
which is pip so you can just open your
command prompt if you're on windows
or you're on a mac open your terminal
and we can just type
python iphone m
install first api
now it's very easy this is just the
command line you need to install fast
api
you can also do the normal way like pip
install first api
or if you're on a mac you can do pip3
install fast api just in normal
installation command lines
so i just like using python iphone m
just personally but you can install it
anyways so
i that is running and as you can see it
says requirement already satisfied
now if you work with python you know
that this means that i already have this
particular library
installed on my computer so because i
have it installed it's not going to go
ahead and install that again
let me just type cls to clear that up so
what that did was it installed fast api
so if you don't have fast api installed
it should go ahead and download some
files and not just only first api some
other stuff that i'm going to use later
like typing and some other libraries
it's going to install that along and
there's one more thing we need to
install
so let's say pip install
uv cone now the reason why we say pip
install if you can this
recon is what we're going to use to run
our web server now if you work with
other libraries like for example django
you know that django you don't need to
install any external thing to run it on
your web server
once you just type a command line if you
have django installed it's going to run
into a web server
but fast api is totally different
because working with fast api
is a very light library so you need like
an external library just to run that
file
on the web server so this uv con is
going to allow us to run
our first api project or file on the web
server
so once i pre press enter now i should
also be expecting requirement already
satisfied
because i have this particular library
installed as you can see
it tells me requirement already
satisfied so let's just
close that up also the next thing i want
to do now
the first thing before i started this i
already
came into my folder i came to this
directory and then i created a python
file named my api dot py
and in my visual studio code i already
opened up that file here
my api dot py but this is the file we're
going to create in our apis and running
everything we're going to do
and what i just want to do is to copy
this particular directory
come into my command prompt and cd into
that
if i press dir right now you can see
that i have that file
there just to make sure that we're in
that particular directory
and now that i know i'm in that
directory let's just go ahead and create
our first api now the reason i just opt
into this directory is just simply
because
when i want to run this on our localhost
on a web server later
i need to make sure i am in that
particular directory so i can run the
file
in that directory so all this is going
to make sense later
but let's just go into visual studio now
first of all
let's just import past api so we can
just do
import past api
and it will save this and come into our
command line and run that
python my api dot py
so if that runs without any error or
anything like that so as you can see
it doesn't give us any or any response
that's just because
there it has to tell us that fast api
has been installed successfully
so let's just close that now let's just
go ahead and create our first api
now what we need to do to create our
first api
we'll save from first api
import first api
exactly so this is just to import first
api
like an object so we're going to use
this object or an instance of this
object to create our apis later
so now that we have this is imported
we're going to say app is equals to
first api
we are taking it from this first api
which we imported
we are creating like an instance of that
first api object
so we can access this later now this
object it has plenty attributes like the
get
let me do let me go into that now but it
has some other things that we're going
to use to
create our api later
so now that we have that created what we
want to do
is to create an end point and let me
explain what an
endpoint is so an end point is one end
of a communication channel
so that's my sound complicated but what
that just means for an api
an endpoint in a url so let's say we
have a url like
on our localhost slash
delete user delete iphone user
so for this particular url
the endpoint is this delete user so this
is like the path
in a normal url we call it the path
let's say we have something like
amazon.com
and then we have something like yeah
just delete user or something like
create user
so this is we can say this is our end
point in the normal url you see the path
but when i deal with api this is like
our end point
so just have that at the back of your
mind and each endpoint
when you're specifying your urls they
might like perform different operations
some might just get a particular
information a particular data
some might be like for example this
create user the end point is
self-explanatory is creating a new user
so that means it we have to post some
data
to that endpoint so we can create a new
user so again you are going to
understand this when we get straight
into it
and there are different type of endpoint
methods but the columns there there are
a lot they are not too much but they are
a lot but the code ones
are get not this
get we have post
we have put and then we have delete
let me just explain this quickly so the
get
is used to just get an information
or return an information
just to get or return a data or
something like that
and then post this is just to create
something new and put it like that with
something new
or create like a new object in the
database
and then for put this port is
used to update a data or to update
something in a particular object so all
this again you are going to understand
when we are
putting all this using all this
practically
for updating and deleting
self-explanatory is just used to delete
something
so as i said this get is just used to
get
or return data or information post is to
create something new or just to add
something new
then put is just to update something
that already exists
in that particular database and delete
is just to delete
like a data from a database or something
like that
so now that we have all these known i
already
understand all this let's just go
straight into creating the real data
the real api so now for me to create a
new api
i'm going to do at the add sign
app dot get and as you can see for this
api i'm using get
and according to the explanation i did
like a few minutes ago
it shows that i want to return an
information or we just want to show an
information
so but if i want to like do something
else like posts pull to delete we're
also going to do all that later in this
video
but let's start with get so after you
say app.get
and notice that this app is getting from
the first api instance which is what we
imported
we're saying app.get and then we're
opening a bracket
put the column output slash so this is
our end point
our endpoint is just the um when we
write slash it means our own
and our own can be like whatever what we
show when we just come to our home page
like
google.com that's the home page so
whatever our domain is that's just
our own page if it's something like
slash
let's say like delete so that is another
like url it can be google.com delete but
now
this is just the home page just to make
sure you get that correctly
but now that we have that we're going to
have a new function
and let's name this index or ohm or
anything we want to name it
and then now let's just return
a particular data
so let's say name
let's say first data
so what this is doing now as we say we
are taking from the app which is also
taken from
the first api object and we're using a
get method
and the end point you specified is just
the home page
or the home url and then under that
we're just gonna
have a new function we can name this
anything we want and what we
i just do is to return this particular
data now this is just a dummy data that
we just input
but later on we can i'm going to show
you how you are going to use it as a
python dictionary
and yeah normally when we're returning
the data
to be written in i'll show you a
response
this api first api uses json but later
also i'm going to show you how we use
a python dictionary and automatically
convert it to json data
so for now this is just a normal json
data that is being
returned let's save this particular file
and for us to run this and really see
what we are doing on like our web server
that's when uv comes in let's go back to
our command prompt
and first to be able to run this let's
just make sure that we're in the
directory of this particular file
and to make sure we just press dir
and then we see our file there that's
good
so now for us to run this we need to
press after returns
the first one we need to add is the name
of the file
which is my api dot py the second one
is the name of the variable you use most
of the time is always
up and then that's basically two things
but let's just since you know that let's
just run
this on the web server what i'm gonna do
now i'm gonna say uv con
i'm gonna leave a space and i'm gonna
say my api which is the name of the file
but now we don't write my api.py we just
write only the name of the file
not with the file extension and then we
put a column
i'll say app and this app is coming from
right here which is the variable we gave
to the object instance of first api
and then we just put two iphones or save
reload
so this is the basic command line just
to run our first api project on our
server
so once we hit enter that should
as you can see it says uvicon running on
this you see application startup
complete
and it gives us this particular url
so this is the url that says where we
should go to to see our project
i'll just come into my browser here
paste that url
hit enter and boom you can see that i
have
name first data which is exactly what we
returned right here as a response name
first data so this is how you can
basically just have a very simple api
now first api has this very cool thing
that
i like and most of everybody that works
with fast api like
which is called the documentation so it
automatically generates this
good looking ui documentation for your
api
if we go to slash docs and we hit enter
you see it says first api swagger ui so
this is just like a basic documentation
for all the apis you have
on this your like website or like your
api application or whatever you want to
call it
so as you can see it says default we
have
from the endpoint of ohm we just slash
and the function is index
which is right here function give it to
this index
and as you can see here is in a get
method that's what it shows yeah that is
a get metal
so it just basically generates this like
api for like this documentation for our
api
and we can test our api directly from
this
place so we don't need to use postman or
any external service to test our api we
can just come here
click on try it out and once i hit
execute
and i come down here it just gives me
the response
which is named first data of whatever is
being done
here now we're also going to go complex
more in the video and show you how to
like manipulate all this data very well
but for now this is just the response
that
is being given back to this page and of
course if we go to the home
it's still that same response so
to this point we've talked about first
of all we created
our first api we make sure we installed
all our
first api uv corner and everything we
needed
i explained endpoint what endpoints are
and
get post put deletes the endpoint method
and here again we created our first api
and also showed you how to use the
documentation of fast api
so that's basically all about
creating and running our first api
now let's talk about an endpoint
parameter
an endpoint parameter is basically used
to return a data
relating to an input in the path or in
the endpoint basically
so we can do that using either a part or
a query so we have two endpoint
parameters which are
a path parameter and a query parameter
i'm going to show you or illustrate
these right now
first of all let's have low year
as i have a new dictionary our name is
students
and i just filled that out correctly
students and let's have a
key which has an id of one and let's
just
have that as another dictionary let's
say
name
let's give it like john
let's have the age
let's say 17
let's have a class
yeah 12 so
so this is just a basic let me make that
small caps
this is just a basic python dictionary
and we just have one field in here this
is a key
and this is the value so what we want to
do now
is that we want to return the data
of this particular student
using the student id so in the
field like let's say slash
we can have a parameter like slash
yet then slash one so once you have one
it means you should return
the data with the student that has
the id of one so before i get into this
let me
explain what i mean by a parts parameter
more so let me just come down here
and let's say i have a website like
google.com
and i have get student
then this is just the basic url to get a
student
and it can just basically show me all
the data
we have in this dictionary but let's say
i want to get only a specific student
like this student which has the id of
one
and i can add another endpoint but now
this endpoint will be dynamic
it's gonna be like a parameter that the
user inputs
it would be something like slash then
can be one then when we go to this url
is the user that has the id of one
that's going to be returned if it's two
it's used as the id of two so let's
cancel this and let's just go straight
into it
so we have this object right here and
then what we want to do
right here in app.get let's first of all
have a new
endpoint app.get also we're using still
using a get
and this time around let's say get
student
so now we have this endpoint name gets
to them and we'll put slash again
and now we want to take a parameter that
means we want to take an id
of what a user should input so first to
do this
we'll use the curly braces and they will
say student
underscore id so this is just telling us
that
students id should basically
be collected and now
say jeff just creating the normal
function and we can say guest student
and now remember right here it was just
blank in here there was nothing in there
but now we are collecting
a student id
underscore id and this should be
equivalent to whatever you put right in
here
so that's what is just being collected
and
we have to specify the data type of this
which is an
integer so the id should be an integer
now
what we can just do is to return
students to our returning students which
is from
here using the student id
so let me explain this one more time
what this is doing now
is that we have this app.get
slash get student slash but now is any
curly braces
let's find like a variable empty like a
variable dynamic variable
so whatever design you put here is what
is going to be used to get
the student so d f get student
and now we're initializing that student
id
saying int so we're giving is like a
data type of int that means
it must not be a string or a boolean
value it has to be an integer
and then we just say return student
so by returning the student with the
student's id
so what i mean by this
you know in a normal python dictionary
if we just want to return
this student because it has a key of one
we can say student
one and this is basically just going to
return
the the value of this one but since we
want this to be dynamic like we want it
to be what the user inputs
we change this one to the student id
that means whatever
the user inputs the key of that is what
should be here
and note let's say user input like five
and we don't have that here
just gonna give you like data found or
something like that so
let's save this first of all and let's
just go test it out
if we come back here
and let's refresh this page so now
you can see that we have a guest student
and it's telling us students underscore
id
so we come here you see that it says
student id is required
that means we can just test this out and
say execute if we try to try this and
execute
see it says that we need to input
something here
now when you put one and say execute
you see now that gives us a response
of name john 17 and year 12. so
that is basically this one right here
so if we come here now and then we try
to put something that is not there like
three and we say execute you see that it
says internal server error that's
because
there is no data like that and of course
let's just go to the
url direct directory directly
so if we say get student
i think student
then slash one you see now that we have
john h
we just have basically that data we say
to internal server error
let's go back to the docs so that's
what's the
path parameter is basically all about
but we can make it
more we can add more details to it or we
can
let's say we can make it composed so let
me come back here
and let's say we want to add more
details to
this student id like
you know when we are serving this api to
a user the user might not really get
like if we didn't name this student's id
and we just say
student because i might not understand
what this is like do you need to pass
the student name
or the student age or the class or the
id so if we don't have a
self-explanation name
we can use like something we need to
import
and then that is gonna allow us to have
a description of
it so the user can know what to input
first of all let's come
up here and input path so we'll say
we don't need to have a downline we can
just press comma and input path
because it's from first api while
importing it
so now that we have part imported well
we can just say
student id column int
equals to and we can say path
first of all we'll say none now this
none
is so that if this student if the person
doesn't input anything he's just gonna
leave it blank or it's not gonna
once it run it's just gonna like bring
out an empty data so that's
to like catch the error remember when we
did it back here
when we tried to get without inputting
something he just
told us that we need to input something
so that's just what this
is doing and now we can add a
description
now in this description we can do
something like it
we want the id of the student
you want to view like that
so now this is just the description we
are giving it and once we have this
if we save it and then we come
to our code right here and let's just
try to refresh the page so
let's refresh docs
and then we say get student
so now you can see right in description
it says the id of the student you want
to view
so just more giving us more description
or more details of what we really want
to collect
but there are also more attributes not
just only these if you come back to our
code
we have more attributes in this path
we have attributes like less than
so let me just quickly come down here
again and explain something
so we have greater than gt
so gt this just means greater than is
self-explanatory we have
less than we have ge which is greater
than or equals to
i also have ld which is less than or
equal to so this is just telling us
since we are collecting
an integer we can specify whether the
integer
we want to collect must not be greater
than 50 or must not be
less than one or zero or something like
that
let's say we don't want our integer to
be
greater than zero
but we want it to be greater than zero
so it must be greater than zero
let's save now we come back here
hit refresh and now
let's try it out right here and let's
say
we try to use zero and say execute
so it gives us this error say ensure the
value is greater than zero
so that's because we specified in here
that we don't want it to be less than
zero it must be greater than zero
and we can also add two let's say want
it to be greater than zero
but less than let's say like three
so that means the number should be from
one to two
so if we go against any of these rules
from here again in the refresh button
and
right here we try it out so let's say we
do three and press execute gonna give us
an error we say ensure the value is less
than three
when if we do two it's going to give us
internal server error
that's because that data is not found
there's no data with the key of two
we've do one
you know we have that data right here
right here we just go here the key of
one
so come back here now you see that gives
us a data
so that's how we can just add more
values
or we can yeah we can add more values
and details to this our particular api
now let's talk about query parameters so
a query is used to pass a value into a
url
so it's quite similar to the part
parameter
let me quickly explain that again
now in a url like let's say
comes google.com and we have results
now when we have this question mark and
then we have
a variable name equals to something like
python
now in this url the query parameter
is this search equals to python
so this is just basically giving us an
like a key and a value so this is the
name of the variable that has been
passed and the value
it's very very very very similar to the
part parameter
the right here and the path parameter
you know we have a
name of student id and we have a value
of whatever the
user inputs that's just how it is here
also we can have like
a url and then instead of having slash
or something
it's going to be on that same end point
but right now
it's going to just have a query attached
to that endpoint
so having this said let's just go
straight into using this practically
what i want to do now is i want to
create a new
let's say a new endpoint i'll say
app.get also and then
let's say slash get
iphone by don't want to get
the student data by the name this right
here we're getting by
the student id but the difference
between the query parameter and the path
parameter is that
in the path parameter we need to add
whatever the
parameter i want to collect in the url
in the end point right here
when you create a parameter we don't
need to do that all we just need to do
is to come into our function
let's find our function and say get
student
and then we just say name
is a string so right here is very
similar you see
in the path with this student id is
equals to an integer
but we already defined our student's id
in the url
but yeah we didn't define anything but
we are now coming to the
function and defining it so once it sees
something that gives it ready
takes it as a query parameter and then
once we have that
we can just go into this our
particular function and now once
a user comes to this uh url and do
something like this and say name
equals to like john we want to get the
data that has the name of john so this
let's do this now and i use a for loop i
say for
student
id in student
if students
web bracket student id
name
goes to the name which was passed and
what we just want to do
is return
students
of that particular student id
none of this is just returned
data
not found so what this is doing is that
first of all sleeping through all the
values we have in this student why is in
the key of student id
in this student so we say if the student
of this student's id the name of it is
requested name which is being passed
but let me explain this well so we are
looping through this student id
using by looking through this student's
dictionary
using the student id and this unit id is
this so we can name this anything right
here we can just say id
any single thing want to name it but if
i say id
python notes can automatically see that
as a keyword so
i'm just going to create a student id so
it's original
so now we are looking through it using
this and we're saying if
the student with this student id
the name of it is equals to the name
which is being passed
they want to return that particular
student if not just say
data not found so now to make a query
parameter let's just go and test it out
let's come back here now we should
good so now we have get by name and we
see here that we are
name required
what we can just do now is say john
and once we eat execute that should work
so as you can see now
his name john because he gets that there
is really
a value or a data with the name of john
when we try something like
let's say a team
and we hit execute we're gonna say data
not found because we don't have any data
right in here
with the name of team so that's
basically how to just create a very
simple
query parameter in fast api now to make
this our query parameter optional
we can do this so it's very simple let's
say we just want to make it optional
like we don't want it required
we come here you'll see that it says it
is required right here
so to make this option now we can just
say name
right here in this string can say equals
to none
once we say equals to none is no more
required we can
go here so come to docs
and we say get by name yes you know it
doesn't say that required again
that means we can try out it's going to
give us an error or something
so it just says data not found but now
is no more required
now that's one way to do it but the best
practice is to use the
default optional method that
fast api as for us so for us to use
this what we just need to do
first of all we'll come right here
it's very easy we just say
optional
and then equals none so this is just
going to make it
optional for us but before we can use
this we need to make sure we put that
optional
say from typing import
optional now this is just to make it
this is the best practice because this
is our first api recommendative from the
documentation
i also do the normal way that i just or
the other way
not the normal way this is the normal
way so we can also do it that way to
keep things simple but we just want you
you have a clean code and a more
readable code that's the main
point to make it more readable we can
also use this
so right now this is gonna be like
not required it's gonna be optional
so now let's say we want to add another
query parameter into it like we want to
have two query parameters how do we do
this
i'm to show you something here let's
just have a comma and say
test int so we just have a query
parameter
of test and is an integer so
if i try to run this we should get an
error and i'm going to show you why we
have that error right now
let me come here not here a browser
so okay you can see that it's not even
going if i come here
now you see that it says syntax error
non-default argument
follows default argument so what this is
just saying is that
we have as you can see right here we
have name
optional and then we have test which is
optional so
python doesn't allow us to
have uh like an optional
argument before a required argument so
fast apec covers this but
python doesn't just allow us because
python is language writing so we also
have to stick with python
so if we come down here one thing we can
do is just switch their places like
change this and bring it here or
something
we can also do that but the best way to
do this so we can have a limited
query parameters and have them anywhere
we want it's very easy what we can just
say aesthetic star
comma so once we have this we can now
write it
if we have a default parameter or
optional or whatever
required it's going to work since we
have this now it's going to be able to
take care of anything that comes
after it now if i come here and hit
refresh
that should work but let's see let's up
that
reloading yeah if we come here now
see it's ready reloading and
that should work now let's give it one
more trial
okay that's taking a while to reload
which you shouldn't but that's just
basically how to
solve that particular error of when
you're having
an optional query parameter before a
required query parameter
so i hope you understand that concept
now let's talk about combining path and
query parameters together
now sometimes you might want to do this
but most of the time you might not
so let's say you want to get two
different values from a user like let's
say his id
and his name or the class or whatever
you might want to combine a query
parameter alongside with a partic
parameter
now for us to do this you know right
here we already have
query parameter of name and test
so let's have a path parameter let's
also call it the student id
slash k
student underscore id
and then since we are defining or
initializing student id in the path and
we also come here
and then say
student underscore id and then we give
it
int say comma so
since we have it here and here that is a
path parameter but if we have it only in
the function that is a query parameter
so that's just the basic difference that
you
just need to take note of so we have it
in these two places does
that so now we can just easily test this
out
actually we even when we collect the
student id we're not going to use it for
anything here because everything we're
just doing is basically
getting it by the name but that's just
how you can combine a query parameter
with that so let's come back here now
we hit enter so if we say get
no this is not what we need we want get
by name
we say get now you see that we have name
test we should also have student id
so let's try it out and
okay if we come back here
then i okay we didn't save our file
let's make sure we save our file
go back tracks
yes and now we have student id which is
also required
so that's just the basic concept of like
combining
a path parameter and a query parameter
together
this part we're going to talk about
request body
and the post method so the request body
this is like
the information or data passed when
creating a new object
using the post method now to do this
first of all
let's import something right here
called the base model so say from
identic import
base model so just to be more
elaborate the request body is like the
data passed when you want to create a
new
object or new data of
these so i'm going to explain this later
like you're going to see what we're
talking about you don't need to like
know the definition or whatever that is
just to know how to use it in a
practical case
so now that we have this base model
imported we're going to create a new
class
and this class we just want it to be
similar to this student
dictionary and let's name the class
student
it's going to take from the base model
let's have a name that should be string
let's have an edge change that as an
integer
and then let's have a class
now i would have loved to have a class
but you can see it's seen it as a
keyword so let's change that to like
a year so the year of the student and
that should be
string also so let's just come here
instead of class here so we can use like
here
so now that we have this what we can
just do we want to create a new path
now but this time around we're going to
use a post method
for us to do this it's just similar but
we'll say
art app dot post
and now we will say create student
now i want to create a new object of
student and we're going to take a path
parameter
or student id and you know what we do
when we take a path parameter we have to
define that
in the function so create
underscore students
so we have to define our student
underscore id as an integer
and what the next thing want to
specify is student so this student now
what it is is basically the details that
the
that the user submits so you know that i
want to create a new
student object for using this particular
class
so now the details let's say the details
the name that the user submit the age
and the year
is what is going to be saved in this
student so we want it to be equals to
this student
model so you can see that this with a
small letter and this letter
capital letter so that's just to show
you the difference so this is like the
key
value so now that we have that
let's just go straight so we say if the
student id that was passed
is in students
now what we just want to do we say
return like an error
and say student exists
so this means that if the student id in
is already in students and this student
already right here then what we just do
is to say
return an arrow that says student
already exists that means they can't
create
the same student with a student with the
same id twice
but if that's not the case you can just
say student
using the student id
equals to student
and i tell you that this student is
whatever the user
brought or submitted using this post
method so now that we have this
we've created a new object of a student
and then we can just basically return
students
of that student id so this is just the
code we need for this
so before we test this code let me
explain what we did in this code again
what we're doing in this code above is
that we are taking a path parameter
of an id so this is part parameter
alongside with all the
details of the student and they were
using that to create a new student
object
so let's just go ahead and test this
code we save that
from here now
docs so now you can see that we have
post not get anymore
create student and student id is
required
and you can see it says request body
also required that's what i talked about
talked about the request body is
basically
the details that's the name the hd year
it needs audios
let's try it out we want to have a
student of
two so
we'll say let's just say team
let's give team age of twelve and say
year nine
now if i execute this
and see now that it just gave me that
response of what i just created
so now we have a student id of two
if i come to get by student id so let's
just get the students using the id
we should have that now saved so let's
say two
and say execute so now we can see that
we have this team
this that means it has been saved right
here but
one thing about this is that it's saving
it in like a memory so if you refresh
this page
that is gone but you know when you're
working with reward applications you
want to save
like your database or something like
that so
you can see that we created a new object
of that now
and then we just use the get to
get that and if we want to create what
already exists like
true i want to create it again i say
execute
you say it says error student already
exists you can create with the same id
twice so that's what's good about that
so let's go back to our code so this is
basically how
we can just use the post method
and the request body to create a new
object in a new object in our data
in our database basically
now let's talk about the puts method as
i explained earlier in this tutorial the
put method is used to update something
that already exists
so to do this first of all let's have a
new
endpoint i'll say app dot
put and this time around
we will say update
i think student
and then want to collect the id of the
student so we know the student
in which we are updating
now let's have a function saying update
student
so we also have to define that student
id as an integer
and now students just similarly to what
we did here
so we know our collecting
that is equals to this student
but now i'm going to explain something
so
right here you can see that we said
student is equal to student
but when we are posting this
posting a particular data to this url
and we say the student is equal to
student everything has to
be accentuated that means all the fields
in their composure so if
we come here now and we give a name
field and we don't give an edge field
it's not going to work if we are using
the students model for the update
so we need to create a new model but
this time around
we'll make all of this optional so the
reason for this is so that because when
a user wants to update the value you
might only want to update the name
and not the age or only wants to update
the year and not the name or
any hour but if we are using this
student class to for the update method
also
the student as the user has to input all
the whole data
that means he has to change audio data
every time he wants to update something
which is not a good practice
so let's just go ahead and create
class and name it update
student
and that's also take from the base model
same thing name
but now we say optional
string what's none just to make it
optional
we'll do the same thing for the age
optional string
na integer
first none and then exactly same thing
for the class
right here we are using here
optional and this is a string
equals none so now we can use
this updates students model
as a reference here so this is not
student taking these updates today
now with this each of it is optional so
if a user gives only one
value the other values can still remain
the same
that's very good and now what we just
want to do
to say if student
id not in student
will say return an error of like these
particular student does not exist or
something so what this
is okay let me quickly write that
so that
under students
does not exist what this is doing is
that first of all it checks
if the student id is not
in student so that means if this the id
which was
being passed so what we're doing is if
we want to update the student we're
going to pass the id of that student
then whatever i want to update
so you will first check if the id is
present in students if it is not present
it will tell you that student does not
exist the students
you want to update does not exist at
least we have to have a student before
we can update that data
so we need to check that first but if it
exists
we can just do something like student
student id
equals to student
and then right now you can just return
students
it's exactly the same thing we did right
here
student id exactly
but i'm going to show you where the
error is in this particular it's not an
arrow
but where the catch is if we come here
now and test this
let's see the refresh button now you can
see is the put we have the put method
down
and you know let's first of all let's
create a new student
so let's try it out that's our creating
with two
and let's say team
12.
year 9. now we execute this
we have a new object or new data
we come to put want to update this
student
so let's try it out and we want to
update the students with the
id of two which is team but now we want
to change the name to tom not
team and we don't need the age or the
year that means these are optional so we
don't want that
it just want to update this if we
execute this now
you will see what will happen so now it
says name
tom and agent null yeah no because we
didn't specify this it says
no if i come all the way to getting
student by
id and i just want to get this student
using two and execute
so what is going to happen now you can
see it doesn't even show us the age
again
it doesn't show that he's 12 years old
or that
he's in year nine so it has been
overwritten so
it because we didn't provide this agent
yeah when we're updating
it just over right write it as no that
means has no value
and this error is coming because we just
did
students with that student id as it goes
to student so this tuner is whatever the
user passes
so since we didn't pass anything it just
updates that student that already has a
value
to update it as nothing which is bad
for us to take care of this we are going
to have to do it in like a manual way
so let's come up here
we'll say if student
that's name
is not supposed to
none
name is if there is something in what
the user passed
and that's where we want to update and
say
students
and id that name
would be updated to the student
this one that name
is exactly the kind of code we want to
use i'm also going to do the same thing
for the age and the class or the year
the if student
dot h
is not equals to none
let's see students without student id
that particular student
does age equals to
student that's h
now for the last time we're gonna have
to do it
for the year but here
not equals to none that means you're not
giving us
an empty value then that's
the only time when we now want to update
so
update a particular value for that
particular key so
if you don't give us something we are
not going to update it
but we give us something we're going to
update it
under here so this is just the code to
take care of that error so now we save
this now this is very good because we've
taken care of that particular arrow
and now let's just go ahead and come
back into
here and then we eat
fresh yes
good so what we want to do first of all
let's
create a new student
to
m 12 years old
you know
let's execute so now we have that now
let's come to our put and update that
team
but now we want him to be 15 years old
so two
and let's leave this name as
blank but now the age wanted to be 15
so you can see that now we didn't pass
the name or the year
but if it executes only
so let's see where the error is coming
from it's expecting proper name and
closing double quotes
okay so it wants this to be in double
code just because it's json data
let's do this and it executes
okay expressing properly name in double
quotes
okay this gives us an error
enclosed in double quotes let's see now
let me tell you where the error is from
if you don't have anything after
it like you do have another value right
here or something
just remove this comma so we don't need
this actually
we should not need that because an
integer so make sure you don't have a
comma at the end if there's nothing
after it so now let's hit
execute and if we come here now you see
that only 15 was updated and it's
highlighted at 15.
so only that 15 was updated and we have
team
and a nice still intact so this is what
we want we can also do it again
and now we can just update that name and
we want that name
to now be tom if we execute
lucida we now have tom age of 15
year over year nine but this is exactly
what we want
if we come back here now and try to get
student
it out let's try to
and you can see that we have the name
tom working perfectly
the age and the year so this is exactly
what we want to get
this is our main goal and let's also
come
down here to the get by name let's test
that
out so let's try it out we have to
we have the name of tom and as i said
this can be anything because we are not
using it
if we execute this now
it gives us an internal server that
because of course that doesn't
it doesn't
not there so let's see slash 2
the name of tom and test32
so the reason why is because we
definitely
changed some values right here or some
code right here
in our where where's that
don't get so can take care of that later
but now that's basically how we can just
update some data in our
in our database if we're using a real
database now we're just using like a
memory like
i would say cookie because the cookie is
on the browser why is it like a memory
once we refresh or like a session once
we refresh that is gone
but now this is how we can just simply
do this and
i hope you understood why we went about
doing things so if you read this code
where you see that i was saying if
is whatever the value is is not known
that means if it is
not empty then now there's something
there that doesn't want to update it
so i hope you all understood what
exactly what we did in this bar
and let's move to the next part
now we are going to look into the delete
method
so the delete method is self-explanatory
just as we delete
the data one object from our database
what we can just do now is to have a new
endpoint
we can say at app dot delete
and then
that is slash delete student
flash let's take the id of the student
we want to delete
as a path parameter and then
define our function
delete student
yeah student
let's go id we want it to be an
integer that's what we're collecting
and now we check if that student id
is not in student
so if he's not in student that means it
doesn't exist then we just return an
error that
what you are trying to delete is not
even in our database it needs to be in
the database for you to be able to
delete it
so error
student does
not exist you need to create a student
first before you can try to delete
but if that's not the case let's just go
ahead with our code
and delete that student
a student's id from the student and they
just return
like a message
saying that
students deleted
successfully now this is a basic code to
just be able to delete
a data or value from a database let's
come here
and test this out
so now if we play around with the
pose first of all we have to create a
new
object before we can do that so let's
say
do
let's go ahead for jerry
20 years that's a year
13 and now let's execute this
okay student exit so um as you can see i
press that twice
so that's why i say student exists if i
come here to my
get so it already created it's when i
press it the first time and i mistakenly
press it again so let's say 2
execute so you can see we have jerry 20
years written
if i come down now to delete you can see
we have this delete function
now that we have this delete function is
write out now by just typing two and
hitting execute
say student deleted successfully now we
might not know if they are related let's
just go ahead
and press check so if we execute now
it says internal server error that's
because the student doesn't exist
again so you also come in now and try to
execute again
it says student does not examine this
today i'm trying to delete
does not exist so this is how we can use
the delete method
in fast api so guys that's gonna be all
for this video
thank you so much for watching till this
point in this video we talked about fast
apis and all the basics and fundamentals
you need
to start working with fast api so thank
you once again for watching this video
and i'll see you in the next one